how big was Creed how big was your band
I tell you
um during our Peak uh we were doing
back-to-back nights at Arenas and had
just started putting stadiums on hold
uh when we uh went our separate ways the
first time
oh and you got separated yes wow yes so
you guys had all that kind of work like
potentially on the books yeah we sure
did we sure did and what what was what
kind of cause like what causes a bandit
that is it just were you guys exhausted
was it just differences of opinion what
kind of causes uh because it would seem
like everything's kind of you know it's
it's so complicated yeah
um I mean for me uh it was exhaustion
from the run to get there
uh mixed with just some poor decisions
um in order to keep the machine going
thinking I was taking one for the team
didn't and not understanding and knowing
the consequences of those actions um and
then just you know people grow apart and
and everyone's dreams
um may not be fulfilled at that moment
in time
uh yeah you know but we got back
together in 2009 and made a new record
and it did did really well and had a
good run until 2012 and and then uh Ron
Hiatus again
was that second run was it different
than the the first experience was it
like most definitely yeah most
definitely uh the first experience was
you know we were family we were brothers
uh we we were in college together we we
did holidays together wow we were all we
had
and the the second experience you know
everyone's successful wealthy
um and you know egos have grown yeah and
and people change and people people grow
uh and uh people grow apart
success is scary it's kind of scary I
feel like did you find that success
became like for me success became real
scary I felt like if I got to a certain
part of success and I didn't know that I
felt this but I thought like a lot of
things in my life would like problems I
had and issues that I had going on that
they would just kind of go away right
and uh and I there was a part of me that
was shocked that that wasn't the case
when I found some success it almost I
mean it really hit me hard that that
wasn't the case yeah it definitely won
the case for me it it act it created new
problems and metastasized old ones yeah
um and then the pressure of maintaining
that
um you know for me the the pressure of
knowing that you know every show rested
on my ability to go out on stage and
sing of course we were abandoned and and
everyone you know had to be present to
be there but I felt such a pressure
um and uh you know that that weight on
me and not having a support system in
place uh you know to help me uh took its
toll and and I didn't make all the right
decisions but hey who does when they're
24 and 25. now I don't beat myself up
over it anymore yeah no
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one